qual è la cosa che più mi fa sentire
vivi al mondo quando è stata l'ultima
volta che avete provato un'emozione
grande per la prima volta io la risposta
a queste domande
lo trovate nel canottaggio mi presento
sono alessandra montesano
ho 18 anni e vengo da un paesino della
provincia di cremona attraversato dal
fiume po ho cominciato a fare
canottaggio a luglio del 2012 e ed è
stata fin da subito un emozione
grandissima per me io sì scusate
l'emozione e nonostante passato
veramente tanti gare non sono comunque
ancora riuscita a gestire questa questa
mia se aveva è normale penso sia comune
la prima è la mia prima volta che parla
un pubblico quindi scusate vivaio ed
emozione quindi
allora dicevo ha iniziato a fare
canottaggio e luglio del 2012 ma
solamente nell'ultimo anno ho realizzato
il primo di una lunga serie di sogni
ovvero entrare a far parte della squadra
nazionale e avere quindi la possibilità
di rappresentare il mio paese e la mia
nazione non solo a livello
internazionale ma anche a livello
mondiale e vi assicuro che portare lo
scudetto sul proprio petto è un'emozione
e una soddisfazione indescrivibile e
arrivare fino a qui non è stato per
niente facile
non solo per l'intensità e la mole degli
allenamenti
infatti mi alleno i sette volte a
settimana durante il periodo scolastico
e 13 14 volte a settimana quindi due
volte al giorno né durante i raduni pre
europei e pre mondiali ma è stato
difficile soprattutto perché ho avuto la
sorpresa di non conoscermi a fondo
infatti tanti sono i miei punti di forza
quanti sono le mie debolezze e il
canottaggio mi ha permesso di conoscerli
tutti perché mette il canottaggio mette
alla prova la nostra resilienza
presidenza ecco questo è il concetto di
cui vi voglio parlare oggi la resilienza
è la nostra capacità di affrontare gli
eventi traumatici e stressanti ma
soprattutto la nostra capacità di far
fronte ad esse di di affrontarli e
quindi di riorganizzare la nostra vita
in maniera positiva e ed è proprio
questo il fulcro del canottaggio
infatti noi ogni giorno dobbiamo
affrontare delle sfide dei problemi
delle difficoltà che in particolar modo
i due canottieri i nostri problemi e
difficoltà che dobbiamo affrontare ogni
giorno sono il dolore e il bruciore
intenso alle gambe alle braccia alla
schiena dovuti al all'acido lattico e
allo stiramento muscolare che in noi
anche solamente dopo pochi minuti di
lavoro raggiunge il picco ma sicuramente
anche voi dovete affrontare delle
difficoltà cioè quando vi ponete un
obiettivo quando avete un sogno da
inseguire e degli obiettivi da
conquistare
sicuramente dovete affrontare dei
problemi delle difficoltà e quando
andate incontro a queste che cosa fate
lievitate cioè rinunciando così al
vostro sogno oppure le affrontate quindi
dovete avere sempre la forza di
affrontare i problemi e superarli perché
solo in questo modo potrete raggiungere
il vostro obiettivo è il vostro sogno
quindi così come nella vita di tutti i
giorni così nel canottaggio la
resilienza è un concetto chiave
quindi noi dobbiamo affrontarle questi
problemi non dobbiamo evitarli
perché solo in questo modo possiamo
raggiungere conquistare il nostro sogno
è il nostro obiettivo
io ho cominciato questo percorso con una
ragazza che è stata la mia compagna di
barca e con cui ho condiviso un intero
anno agonistico ma a dire il vero le
nostre gare non andavano per niente bene
anzi arrivavamo sempre tra le ultime e
spesso non ci riuscivamo a qualificare
nemmeno per le semifinali
quindi eravamo proprio un disastro
totale invece di percorrere il campo
dritto quindi affiancato alle boy noi
giustamente ci facevamo lo slalom perché
2000 metri di gara non erano abbastanza
e quindi ci raggiunge raggiungevamo
qualche centinaio poi però abbiamo avuto
il nostro piccolo riscatto dopo tanti
allenamenti siamo riusciti a vincere il
primo campionato regionale ed è stata
un'emozione grandissima
e anche perché comunque il nostro
percorso è stato sostenuto dal nostro
allenatore e oro olimpico a seul nel
1988 quindi un grande punto di
riferimento per noi un punto di
ispirazione
e appunto abbiamo visto abbiamo vinto
questo campionato regionale ed è stata
un'emozione grandissima perchè ce
l'avevamo fatta dopo tanto tempo eravamo
riusciti a raggiungere il nostro primo
piccolo obiettivo
poi però abbiamo avuto entrambe un grave
problema alla schiena
e infatti abbiamo dovuto abbandonare
avete presente la sensazione quando
tutto sembra andare per il meglio e poi
vi sentite cadere il mondo addosso
ecco ed è esattamente così che noi ci
siamo sentite ed è stato brutto perché
noi siamo passate da lottare ogni giorno
per conquistare il nostro sogno per
raggiungere il nostro obiettivo
ad essere costrette ad abbandonare a
stare lontano dalla nostra passione
l'anno successivo nel 2014
io ho ripreso ad allenarmi
lei purtroppo ha abbandonato
completamente e per me è stato ancora
più difficile ricominciare perché non
solo perché ormai avevo perso parte
della mia forma fisica ma soprattutto
perché ero da sola io prima aveva una
compagna di barca con cui condividere
non solo le gioie delle delle vittorie
ma soprattutto le sconfitte
la paura l'ansia ma anche la sofferenza
degli allenamenti mentre adesso la mia
compagna di barkan ero solamente io
quindi dovevo fare solo affidamento su
di me e non è stato per niente facile
neanche per le mie prime gare infatti
arrivavo sempre tra le ultime è ancora
una volta non riusciva a qualificarmi
nemmeno per le semifinali
però io non mi sono arresa io ho
continuato nonostante le delusioni
fossero grandissime ve lo assicuro
perchè quando avete un grandissimo sogno
e nonostante voi provate e riprovate non
ci riuscite mai solitamente
si vuole arrendere perché non si riesce
più a trovare la forza e la motivazione
di andare però io sono contenta di
essere riuscite vorrei che anche voi
faceste la stessa cosa
così ho continuato ad allenarmi e ho
avuto il mio primo piccolo riscatto a
settembre 2015 dov'è il mio primo
campionato italiano sono arrivata quinta
nonostante non avessi preso medaglie ero
comunque contenta perché per la prima
volta ero riuscita ad affrontare
batterie semifinali ed essere arrivati
in finale e quindi il mio primo piccolo
obiettivo era stato quello qui il mio
primo piccolo passo verso un grande
sogno era quello
e poi ho continuato ad allenarmi e io ho
continuando ad allenarmi con la stessa
motivazione con la stessa forza ho
cominciato a farmi conoscere alle prime
gare regionali
ho cominciato ad infastidire quelle che
erano le atlete più forti fino appunto a
vincere il mio primo titolo tricolore
e questo titolo tricolore l'ho vinto
quest'anno a a giugno giugno 2016 a
ravenna
nello stesso bacino in cui abbiamo fatto
il campionato italiano l'anno precedente
quindi mi sono ritrovate da sconfitte
invece a vittoriosa e questa è stata
l'emozione più grande perché ovviamente
dopo tanto tempo ce l'avevo fatta
nonostante avessi fatto gli anni
precedenti a la paura di non essere
riuscito a dimostrare quello che
realmente valessi quello che realmente
fossi era quella la finale mia paura più
grande perché quando voi fate qualcosa
però voi siete coscienti di poter fare
tanto di poter dare tanto e quando non
ci riuscite
vi sentite abbattuti ma soprattutto
arrabbiati perché dite io sono capace di
fare questa cosa perché non riesco a
farlo perché non riescono anche a
dimostrarlo agli altri quindi questa era
la mia paura più grande è però alla fine
sono riusciti a superarla e così dovete
fare anche voi quindi il concetto di
resilienza è il concetto chiave così nel
canottaggio così nella vita di tutti i
giorni
ma quindi questo è anche il carattere
fondamentale di un canottiere ma un
altro aspetto inconfondibile sono le
mani allora magari non tutti sita a
vederla ma queste sono le mie mani
durante tutto l'inverno e sui pieni di
vesciche e di calli ma nonostante questo
e nonostante possa sembrare strano
perche sono una ragazza io adoro i miei
calli perché sono la fine
l'incarnazione del del mio lavoro della
mia passione insomma sono una memoria
che porto incarnata nelle mie mani
questo penso sia una cosa bellissima
io adoro
amo il canottaggio perché mi ha messo in
crisi e mi ha messo in crisi perché
questo sport non è faticoso è spietato
ve lo assicuro e ti costringe ad essere
te stesso senza regalarti nulla cioè
tutto ciò che ottieni o non ottieni e
merito o demerito tuo non c'è una via di
fuga via di scampo devi affrontare
ancora una volta tutto ciò che ti viene
incontro è però le le rinunce che ho
fatto e che continua a fare sono tante
ma una cosa a cui non sono mai riuscite
a rinunciare è la scuola e quindi lo
studio infatti sono all'ultimo anno del
liceo scientifico tradizionale e
nonostante sia molto difficile
coinciliare studi agonismo è comunque
possibile si può fare e spero che possa
essere possibile
comunque questa collaborazione in modo
tale da da poter dare sempre magari più
più crediti e importanza non solo a chi
si impegna a scuola ma anche chi si
impegna al di fuori della scuola e penso
quindi che sia una anche un'opportunità
bellissima quella che sto avendo adesso
perché comunque io parlo con voi
condivido con voi la mia storia e spero
che comunque nonostante magari non
facciate canottaggio riuscite riuscite a
me a trovare insomma la forza la
motivazione per per raggiungere i vostri
obiettivi e quindi spero e mi piacerebbe
poter essere d'esempio a tutti i ragazzi
e le ragazze come me appunto affinché
per severino inseguono i loro sogni
ponendosi degli obiettivi da raggiungere
ma soprattutto dei limiti da da
abbattere perché bisogna imparare a
convivere con la fatica e io ho imparato
addirittura ad amarla
molti sostengono che il canottaggio non
non lascia spazio e tempo per fare altro
ma non sono d'accordo perché il
canottaggio ti premia con una nuova vita
una vita di sfide soprattutto con te
stessa
una vita di traguardi da raggiungere i
traguardi raggiunti ma soprattutto di
traguardi mancati che però non devono
essere solo una fonte di delusione ma
devono essere la motivazione giusta per
continuare riprovarci e migliorare
infatti voi dovete credere nella vostra
forza di volontà perché è solamente la
forza di volontà che vi permette di
affrontare tutto quanto cioè questa
forza di volontà deve essere più grande
del dolore più grande delle difficoltà
dovete vivere una una vita che vi
ricorderete perché non dovrete essere
solamente un tuono ma dovrete essere la
tempesta della vostra vita